[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه ماي ليلى الاختيار استهلها بابرز
العدو
من بغداد واشنطن وبردين تحذران ايران و
ميليشياتها اياكم من تعريض العراق
والمنطقه للخطر
بخموت في طريقها للسقوط بيد القوات
الروسيه اوكرانيا تنفذ انسحابا غير معلن
منها
تروي للعربيه قصه تطوعها في القتال على
الجبهات الاماميه ضد روسيا
وفي ملف تصميم الطالبات بايران اكثر من
5000 حاله والغاز السام يقتحم القطارات
ايضا
[موسيقى]
نبدا مشاهدينا من العراق والزياره التي
قام بها وزير الدفاع الامريكي الى بغداد
زياره صنفت في خانه التاكيد على التواجد
الامريكي في العراق وضروره مواجهه ايران
وميليشياتها في المنطقه اصل شدد على ان
رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شيع السوداني
اكد له ضمانه امن القوات الامريكيه في
العراق من جهات غير تابعه للدوله في اشاره
الى الميليشيات المواليه لايران
يجب ان نكون قادرين على العمل بسلامه
وامان لتنفيذ دورنا الحيوي بتقديم المشوره
للقوات العراقيه لذا اود ان اشكر رئيس
الوزراء السوداني ووزير الدفاع العباسي
على التزامهما اليوم بضمان ان قوات
التحالف الموجوده في العراق بطلب عراقي
ستتم حمايتها من العناصر التابعه وغير
التابعه للدوله نركز على مهمه هزيمه داعش
هذا هو هدفنا الوحيد هنا والتهديدات
والهجمات على قواتنا تقوض مهمتنا
هل تحذروا الامريكي لظهران شاركه اخر
الماني اذا انتقدت وزيره خارجيه المانيا
التدخل الايراني في العراق قائله ان
النظام يضع المنطقه باسرها تحت التهديد
اشتعلت
[موسيقى]
على الدول ان تحترم سياده العراق كما
نتوقع منها ان تحترم سياده كل الدول
الاوروبيه ويظهر النظام الايراني بهجمته
الصاروخيه انه لا يضطهد شعبه بقسوه ووحشيه
فحسب بل يضع حياه الناس والاستقرار في
المنطقه كلها تحت الخطر في سبيل الحفاظ
على قوته وهذا امر غير مقبول وخطير على
المنطقه كامله
لمزيد مشاهدينا حول هذه الزياره ينضم
الينا من بغداد منتظر رشيد مراسل العربيه
منتظر يعني كيف تقرا الاوساط السياسيه في
بغداد هذه الزياره الامريكيه والدعم
الغربي للتاكيد على عدم السماح لايران
باحداث اي تغيير على موازين القوى داخل
بغداد
يعني بالنسبه لوزير الدفاع الامريكي تحدث
وان كان ذلك بشكل غير مباشر عن ضروره
حمايه
المستشارين الامريكيين العسكريين
الامريكيين الذين يتواجدون في العراق في
اكثر من قاعده عسكريه في حرير في اربيل
وايضا قاعده فيكتوري في هذه القواعد طلب
وزير الدفاع السلطات العراقيه بحمايه
هؤلاء اضافه الى حمايه قوافل الدعم
اللوجيسي القادمه من الكويت والتي تذهب
باتجاه هذه القواعد بشكل
اسبوعي تقريبا اكثر من قافله تاتي هذه
القوافل دائما ما كانت تتعرض لها هجمات
توقفت هذه الهجمات قرابه الاربعه اشهر
لكنها تعرضت الى هجومين مؤخرا ربما هذا ما
اكد عليه طبعا وزير الدفاع الامريكي عند
لقائه طبعا بكبار المسؤولين العراقيين
وعلى راسهم طبعا القائد العام القوات
المسلحه رئيس الحكومه محمد الشيعه
السوداني اضافه الى ملف اخر ايضا اكد عليه
هو تطوير التعامل في هذا المجال المجال
مجالات التدريب اضافه الى مجال تبادل
المعلومات القوات الامريكيه تساعد القوات
العراقيه وتحديدا جهاز مكافحه الارهاب في
تنفيذ اكثر من عمليه صعبه جدا تحتاج الى
دعم امريكي بالمعلومات بالرصد اضافه الى
النقل ايضا يحتاج العراقي الى بعض
الطائرات الامريكيه من نوع خاص لكي ينفذ
مثل هذه العمليات في اصطياد قياديين طبعا
في داعش هناك عدم ترحيب طبعا من قبل
الفصائل المسلحه اكثر من مسؤول وقياتي غرد
منتقدا هذه الزياره بعضهم وصفها بانها
زياره غير مرحب بها هكذا قالوا طبعا في
تغريداتهم التي تابعناها طبعا طوال
الساعات القليله الماضيه والتي صدرت بعد
هذه الزياره التي قالوا ايضا انها زياره
غير معلنه لم ياتي من الباب كما ذكروا
وانما جاء من الشباك لكن ربما لدواعي
امنيه طبعا لم يتم الاعلان مسبقا عن وجود
مثل هذه الزياره لوزير الدفاع الامريكي
لكن هذا مجمل الملفات التي ناقشها وهذه
ايضا ردود الافعال طبعا من قبل الجهات
التي تعتبرونها نفسها مستهدفه طبعا سواء
بتصريحاتي وزير الدفاع الامريكي وحتى
وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه التي تحدثت ايضا
وانتقدت ايران ودور ايران ايضا في المنطقه
شكرا لك منتظر رشيد مراسل العربيه حدثتنا
من بغداد
سيطره روسيه قريبه على بخموت ان لم تكن
اليوم فخلال ايام قليله تقول التطورات على
الارض وتؤكدها مصادر اوكرانيه ايضا لكن
ومع اقتراب القوات الروسيه برفقه مجموعه
فاجنر من الاستيلاء على كامل المدينه
الصناعيه
يبحثا سريا تكتيكيا من المدينه
هذه اول وحده من حرس الحدود الوضع في
المدينه صعب للغايه العدو يقتحم مواقعنا
بفعاليه ومع ذلك لم يحالفهم اي نجاح
وتكبدوا خسائر فادحه حاولوا تفجير جسرين
ولكننا ما زلنا نتلقى كل ما نحتاجه
المدينه قائمه ضخمه كانت وستظل جزءا من
اوكرانيا
وبالحديث مشاهدينا عن الانسحاب فدعونا
نشرح الانسحاب الافتراضي الذي قد تنفذه
القوات الاوكرانيه من باخمت حيث ينظم
الاوكرانيون وفقا تقرير مناورات للفرمله
هذه المناورات يقوم بها الجيش الاوكراني
الان على خط الجبهه هناك طبعا الخروج
بخسائر وباقل خسائر ممكنه من هذه الجبهه
بجبهه بخموت تتمركز هنا القوات الاوكرانيه
حيث تقوم
بنشر خط دفاع اول يساند خط الدفاع الثاني
ويسان الطبعا خط الدفاع الثالث وبالتالي
خطوط دفاع متتاليه لكي يتم خروج القوات
الاوكرانيه من بخموت عبر هذا الطريق دعوني
ان اشير اليه الطريق من هنا غربي جبهه
باخموت الى
وطبعا تنسحب القوات الاوكرانيه من هذه
المنطقه التي تعتبر يعني خط الخروج الذي
يجنب القوات الاوكرانيه مزيد من الخسائر
في العتاد وفي العديد وهذه هذا الخط الذي
اشرت اليه هنا هو خط الامداد الرئيسي
للقوات الاوكرانيه بهذه المنطقه وهو طبعا
ما تحاول الان قوات فاجنر بالذات من
السيطره عليه عبر ضرب خط الامدادات هذا
بمزيد من الضربات ان كان المدفعيه وان كان
طبعا عمليات تفجير لكي يتم يعني قطع قطع
الامداد وبالتالي الحاق اكبر قدر من
الخسائر بالقوات الاوكرانيه في ضخمه
[موسيقى]
ماركه باخموت التي اشعلت الشتاء الاوكراني
باتت تحمل الرمزيه الاكبر في الصراع
الروسي الاوكراني
المدينه التي تسمى ايضا
تقع شرقيه اوكرانيا شماليه اقليم دونيتس
تحديدا والذي تتقاسم القوات الروسيه
والاوكرانيه السيطره عليه القتال الدموي
المستمر منذ اشهر في المدينه والذي حمل
تقدم الروسيا في الايام الاخيره ادى الى
قطع الطرق المؤديه اليها باستثناء طريق
وحيده تصل الى الغرب سلطات دنيا المواليه
لروسيا تزعم ان القوات الروسيه استطاعت
السيطره على نصف المدينه محققه تقدما من
الجهتين الشماليه والجنوبيه
قتال مستميد تراه موسكو ذا اهميه
استراتيجيه كبيره للتوغل باتجاه الغرب
الذي تسيطر عليه كييف خاصه وان الهدف
التالي سيكون المدينتين المفتاحتين
كراماتورسك وسلفيانك
تشكل المدينه مركزا دفاعيا مهما للقوات
الاوكرانيه في منطقه دومباس والسيطره
عليها ستسمح بهجمات اضافيه في عمق خطوط
الدفاع القوه المسلحه الاوكرانيه لكن رغم
كل هذه الاهميه من وجهه النظر الروسيه فان
واشنطن تقصر اهميه المدينه على الناحيه
الرمزيه وليس الاستراتيجيه وتؤكد ان
التقدم الروسي فيها لن يعني تغيير مسار
المعركه الى عمر العربيه
الخلاف بين مؤسس مجموعه فاجنر ووزاره
الدفاع الروسيه وصف بالصيد الثمين
لاوكرانيا حيث تخطط القوات الاوكرانيه
للاستفاده من هذا الخلاف في مدينه باخموت
المحاصره وفق ما نشرته مجله
السابق للرئيس الروسي اكد وجود نسختين من
الاحداث لشرخ
الشرق ارسال كياف تعزيزات الى باخمه
اوكرانيا اولها امكانيه تخطيط اوكرانيا
لهجوم مضاد كبير في باخمود عبر استهداف
اجنحه مجموعه فاجنر ثم يمضون قدما في
المهاجمه فيما ثاني الخيارات وفق الموظف
السابق في الكريم لن يتمثل بسماح هذه
التعزيزات لاوكرانيا بخروج منظم من
المدينه
[موسيقى]
قال قائد مجموعه فاغنر ان الاسلحه التي
تحتاجها قوته للقتال في جبهه باخموت لم
تصل لقوات حتى الان واضاف انه من المبكر
الحديث عن ما بعد باخموت لان المعركه
مستمره وليست سهله مشيرا الى ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تقاتل بشراسه في باخموت ولا
تستسلم بسهوله وذلك في رد على تصريحات
وزير الدفاع الروسي سرقه
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا حذيفه عادل مراسل
العربيه حذيفه يعني عندما نتحدث عن باخمت
تشكل طبعا مركزا دفاعيا مهما للقوات
الاوكرانيه هناك ما هي الاجواء يعني في
كياف مع التضارب حول موضوع يعني انتهاء من
هذه الجبهه ووقوع بيض الروس
مساء الخير العيال في الحقيقه الان جبهه
باخموت اصبحت تمثل جبهه رئيسيه في القتال
بين القوات الروسيه والقوات الاوكرانيه في
الجبهه الشرقيه تحديدا وهي الجبهه النشطه
يعني ما عدا ذلك اذا تحدثنا عن لوغانسك
فالجبهه متحركه ولكنها متحركه بشكل بطيء
اما في جهه فهنالك جمود في عمليات
الاقتحام والتقدم ولكن طبعا القصف يتواصل
وكذلك في الجبهه اخرسون اما بخموت فهي
المدينه الاساسيه التي يحاول الروس الان
السيطره عليها واصبحت اوكرانيا تنظر الى
مخموت بشكل مختلف تماما هي لا تنظر اليها
كمدينه تدافع عنها فلم تعد هنالك مدينه
كما تقول السلطان في دونيسك ان المدينه
دمرت بشكل كبير جدا بقي في المدينه ما بين
4000 او اقل من 4000 هذا اخر احصائيه
اليوم ان من بقي في المدينه اقل من 4000
وهنالك جهود جاريه لعمليه اجراء
المواطنين ايضا هنا لابد ان اشير الى انه
تم اتخاذ قرار اليوم من مجلس الوزراء
الاوكراني باجلاء الاطفال قصرا وكان هذا
الامر يمنعه القانون كانت السلطان تاتي
الى الاهالي في مدينه بخموت او في اي جبهه
فيها قتال نصب وتطالبهم بالرحيل اذا رفض
الاهل لا يستطيعون ان يفعلوا شيء ولكن
الان تم اتخاذ القرار واصبح الان هنالك
قانون لاجلاء الاطفال قصريا اذا وافق
الاهل هنالك عمليه اجلاء تتم مع الاهل او
مع احد الوالدين او من هو مسؤول عن هذا
الطفل واذا لم يوافق الاهل يتم قصرا ذلك
بمرافق من السلطات القانونيه هذا من جانب
المدينه الان ينظر اليها كجبحه استراتيجيه
الهدف الرئيسي كما اشار شريفاتي انه هو
تدمير القدره القتاليه للقوات الروسيه
وذلك لان القوات الروسيه تركز بشكل كبير
على هذه الجبهه وتدفع بكميات كبيره من
الاليات والمعدات والجنود لذلك اصبح الهدف
الان هو تدمير القطره القدره واستنزاف
القوات الروسيه في هذه الجبهه وهذا هو
الهدف الاستراتيجي الان بالنسبه
للاوكرانيين من هذه الجبهه يؤكدون انه ما
زالوا يسيطرون وان هنالك الدفاعات قويه
جدا نعم هنالك اقتحام وتقدم مستمر ليال من
جميع الجهات الثلاث من جهه
وكذلك هنالك تقدم للقوات الروسيه كذلك من
الجهه الشماليه هنالك تقدم ولكن هنالك
يعني اعلانات عن ان الجهه الشماليه تم
تعزيز الدفاعات ايضا السلطات هنا في كيف
اتخذت القرار بدفع مزيد من التعزيزات
للقوات في تلك لنتحدث يعني عن جبهه مصريه
ويعني مفصليه بهذه الحرب شكرا لك حذيفه
عادل مراسل العربيه حدثنا منك
اثار مقطع فيديو متداول على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي
اتهام جنود رؤوس باعدام جنديه اوكراني يقف
في خندق وهو يدخن سيجاره قبل ان يطلق عليه
الرصاص بسلاح علي بعد هتافه المجد
لاوكرانيا اثار هذا الفيديو ردود فعل
كبيره ورسميه في اوكرانيا فلنتابع
ردود فعل رسميه اوكرانيه على انتشار مقطع
فيديو يظهر اعدام جنود الروس لاسير حرب
اوكرانيه
المجد للبطل المجد للابطال المجد
لاوكرانيا
اندريكو المدعي العام في اوكرانيا سيتولى
مدعون قياده القضيه عاجلا ام اجلا سيعاقب
كل من يشارك بمثل هذه الاعمال وفقا
للقانون
بمترو كوليبا وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني يجب
ان تطلق المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه تحقيقا
فوريا في جريمه الحرب الشنيعه هذه
[موسيقى]
اندريه مدير مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني هذه
سياسه الارهاب الممنهجه التي تعمل على
تبييضها دعايه الكرملين باساطرها عن
النازيين
التقت العربيه باشهر قناصه اوكرانيه قاتلت
وتزوجت وحملت بطفلتها في خط النار وصفها
الاعلام الروسي باشهر قناصا انضمت للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه متطوعه مع بدايه الحرب
لتصبح من اهم القناصين الذين يؤدون مهام
قتاليه في الخطوط الاماميه فلنتابع
في السادس من سبتمبر من العام 2018 وافق
البرلمان الاوكراني على مشروع قانون
لتعديل بعض القوانين لضمان المساواه في
الحقوق والفرص بين النساء والرجال اثناء
الخدمه العسكريه في القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه حيث تخدم الان اكثر من 50 الف
امراه في الجيش الاوكراني 37 منهن عسكريا
وثلاثه عشر الفا في الجيش في مناصب اداريه
ومدنيه في الوقت الذي تقاتله ما يزيد عن
الخمسه الاف مقاتله في خطوط النار
الاماميه من بينهن ضابطات
التي سماها الروس بالقناصه الفاشيه
الاوكرانيه كانت قبل الحرب سيده اعمال
تمارس صناعه الحلي الا انها كانت تهوى
القنصه وتمارسه منذ الطفوله
قبل الحرب الشامله على اوكرانيا كنت امراه
عاديه وكان لدي الرؤيه الخاص لقد كانت لدي
حياه رائعه وناجحه وكانت لدي كثير من
الخطط الحياتيه جنسنا
الى صفوف القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
كمتطوعه للدفاع عن بلادها عند بدايه الحرب
وانخرطت في تدريبات مكثفه للقناصه مستفيده
من خبرتها في الرمايه والقنص حتى اصبحت من
القناصه القلائل الذين توكل اليهم مهام
قتاليه في اخطر واصعب الجبهات
كنت ارغب بالذهاب الى القتال قبل عشره
اعوام عندما انتهيت من دراسه العسكريه
وحصلت على تعليمي العسكري لذلك الان عندما
قررت كان من السهل علي الالتحاق بالجيش
كنت محظوظه ان اذهب الى القناصه
لم تتوقف الاثاره في حياه القناصه
الاوكرانيه في الجبهه عند القتال والمعارك
الضاريه بل امتدت الى حياتها الشخصيه حيث
عثرت على حب حياتها هناك الضابط الذي تقدم
لخطبتها في خط النار حيث عقد قرانهما في
الادغال
تعرفت على زوجي عن طريق وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي فقد كنا في الويه مختلفه وخدمنا
في ولايه مختلفه بعد اسبوعين حضر للتعرف
على قائد واخبرهم الا يقلقوا وانه عسكري
وشخص جيد وستكون قناصتهم بخير معه وتقدم
في ذات اليوم لخطبتي فعليا لقد كانت تلك
المره الثانيه التي نلتقي فيها وتزوجنا في
خط النار مباشره لقد كان ذلك السريعا
ورومانسيا جدا وبعد ان تزوجت نشر الاعلام
الروسي ووصفني باشهر قناصه فاشيه اوكرانيه
تزوجت
من عنصري اخر مثلها لا تختلف عن القصص
كثير من النساء في الخطوط الاماميه منهن
قائدات لراجمات الصواريخ والدبابات
وقائدات طائرات دون طيار ومسعفات طبيه في
اكثر المناطق سخونه تمثل النساء في القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه 22 بالمئه وهي واحده
من اعلى المعدلات بين جيوش الدول
الاوروبيه اذا في عادل العربيه كيف
نبقى مشاهدينا في الملفات الحربي اوكرانيا
اذا اعلن وزيره الدفاع البولندي لتزويد
اوكرانيا بعشر دبابات اضافيه من طراز
المانيات صنع هذا الاسبوع من جهته ومن جهه
اخرى قال وزير الدفاع ان قرار امداد
اوكرانيا المحتمل بالمقاتلات الجويه
الغربيه يجب اتخاذه على مستوى الحلفاء في
الناتو مشيرا الى الاستمرار في تعزيز
الدفاعات الاوكرانيه ببطاريات
ودبابات واوضح وزير الدفاع البولندي
انوارثو قدمت منذ بدايه الصراع مساعدات
عسكريه لكلاب تزيد عن اثنين مليار دولار
او مليار يورو
وقبل ذلك قال وزير الدفاع الالماني ان
الناتو ليس لديه اي نقص في معدات دبابات
مضيفا الى ان المشكله كانت فقط بتاخر
الصيانه والاصلاح وكانت صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز قد ذكرت سابقا ان المانيا وحلفائها
يكافحون منذ اسابيع لتجميع ما يكفي من
دبابات من اجل تشكيل كتيبتين من الدبابات
بما مجموع اثنين
دببهم كان
ليس لدينا اي نقص في معدات دبابات علي
الاختلاف مع ذلك بوضوح شديد كان لدينا
تاخير في الصيانه والاصلاح ويجري العمل
على ذلك لكن الاصول التي تمكنا من تجديدها
هي في فرقه العمل المشتركه ذات الجاهزيه
العاليه والامر ليس بذلك السوء كما قرات
هذا الصباح هذه اداره طبيعيه للموارد
عندما تتعطل المركبات او تصعب صيانتها
بسرعه كافيه يتم استبدالها بمركبات اخرى
ذات قيمه متساويه والتي تضمن مع المركبات
الموجوده امكانيه انجاز المهمه ولا شك في
ذلك
ومع
دخول السلسلات المساعدات العسكريه للجيش
الاوكراني لكن بالنسبه لبريطانيا فالقصه
مختلفه تماما مع حاله التململ في اوساط
بعض البرلمانيين البريطانيين نتيجه نقص
مخزونات الذخيره والسبب المساعدات المقدمه
للجيش الاوكراني
حرب اوكرانيا تهدد مخزونات الذخيره
البريطانيه لاول مره منذ سنوات طويله
بريطانيا تسجل نقصا فادحا في الذخيره
والسبب المساعدات المقدمه للجيش الاوكراني
تملول واستياء ومخاوف كبيره في اوساط بعض
البرلمانيين البريطانيين صاحبتها تحذيرات
من ان اعاده بناء مخزون بريطانيا من
الذخائر قد يستغرق عقدا على الاقل
دعوات حكوميه لتقليص الوقت اللازم
لاستعاده مستويات مخزونات بريطانيا من
الذخيره وكاله البريطانيه الامن القومي
البريطاني بات تحت الخطر بسبب انخفاض
احتياطيات الذخيره الى مستويات خطيره في
الوقت الذي تسعى فيه الدول الغربيه الى
ابقاء كييف مزوده بالذخيره الحربيه عدم
قدره المملكه المتحده على استعاده مستويات
مخزوناتها يعرض قدرتها على اعاده تزويد
الجيش الاوكراني للخطر ويعرضها لخطر عدم
القدره على مواجهه التهديدات التي تطال
امنها في المستقبل
رئيس البلاروسيا الكسندر لوكاشينكو
المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه ومجموعات
اوكرانيه بالوقوف وراء هجوم مزعوم على
طائره عسكريه روسيه بالقرب من العاصمه وهو
ما نفته اكياف
لاحقاينه عمل جهاز الامن الاوكراني وكذلك
وكاله المخابرات المركزيه سرا وبشكل مشترك
على عمليه ضد جمهوريه بيلاروسيا ما رايناه
في تنفيذ العمليه في بيلاروسيا كان حقا
شيئا لا يصدق تم استخدام اكثر التقنيات
تقدما تلقى المهاجم تدريبا كاملا واستعد
لاكثر من شهر بعد التدريب كما تقول
المخابرات السوفياتيه على اراضينا
التاسعه مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد
قليل مقتل سته فلسطينيين باقتحام القوات
الاسرائيليه لمخيم جنين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد ضربه اسرائيليه ثانيه في
سوريا بعد الزلزال المدمر استهدفت مطار
حلب الدولي الواقع جنوب شرقي المدينه
الغارات الاسرائيليه ضربت مدرج مطار حلب
ثاني اكبر مطارات سوريا بعد مطار دمشق في
الساعات وفي الساعه الثانيه وسبع دقائق
فجرا الضربه اتت من ناحيه البحر الابيض
المتوسط غربيا اللاذقيه والحقت اضرارا
ماديه في مدرج المطار ليخرج عن الخدمه دون
وقوع اي اصابات بشريه وفق مصادر النظام
السوري وبالتالي يعجز المطار حاليا
مشاهدينا عن استقبال اي طائره جديده حتى
يتم اصلاح الاضرار التي لحقت فيه وعلى
اثره قررت وزاره النقل تحويل هبوط طائرات
المساعدات والرحلات الجويه المقرره
للمطارات دمشق واللاذقيه كما دعت
المسافرين للترتيب امور سفرهم مع شركات
الطيران وفقا لهذا الترتيب وبحسب وكاله
سانا النظام السوري فان الدفاعات السوريه
الجويه تصدت للصواريخ لكن احدها افلت من
المضادات واستهدف المهبط الرئيسي للمطار
هذا وكثفت اسرائيل العام الماضي كما نذكر
ضرباتها على المطارات السوريه لتعطيل خطوط
امداد ايران الجويه لايصال الاسلحه الى
ميليشياتها في سوريا ولبنان
وبمقدمتهم حزب الله
[موسيقى]
الى ايران وقضيه تسميم الطالبات في
المدارس والجامعات فمع تازم هذا الملف
وتخبط النظام ومسؤوليه في تفسير الحاله او
الحالات التي ارتفعت اصاباتها الى اكثر من
خمسه الاف حاله تصميم متعمد وسائل الاعلام
محليه قالت بان وزاره الداخليه الايرانيه
اعلنت اعتقال اشخاص على صله بقضيه تصميم
الطالبات جاء ذلك على لسان مساعد وزير
الداخليه الايراني للشؤون الامنيه الذي
اشار الى اعتقال بعض الاشخاص في خمس
محافظات على صله بتسميم الطلاب
[تصفيق]
خريطه هجمات السم الخفيف كما وصفت تتوسع
في ايران وكان التسمم بات معديا فمن
المدارس الى الجامعات ومن ثم مؤخرا محطات
القطارات اكثر من 120 مدرسه تعرضت فتياتها
للتسمم بالغاز او بالماده التي عجزت
السلطات الايرانيه حتى اللحظه من تحديد
ماهيتها المدارس التي تخطى عددها المئه
توزعت على اكثر من 25 محافظه بينها
كردستان وفارس وطهران ولورستان وصفهان
وكرمان بالاضافه الى عده جامعات ايضا
ومؤخرا ما زاد من خطوره الامر هي حالات
تسمم سجلت لفتيات ايرانيات داخل محطات
المترو والقطارات كما حدث مع العديد من
مستخدمات المترو بهارستان في اصفهان صباح
اليوم ايران انترناشونال اكدت اظهار مقاطع
فيديو لتدهور الحاله الصحيه الفتيات ولحجم
الزحام في المستشفيات فلنتابع
[موسيقى]
النظام الايراني متمسك بروايه تعدد المواد
المستخدمه بالهجمات وبعضها مواد متاحه
يمكن ان تسبب تهيجا وفق وزاره الصحه حيث
قللت الوزاره طبعا من حجم واهميه ما يجري
لافته الى ان بعض الطالبات اللواتي تعرضن
للهجوم صبنا باعراض في الجهاز التنفسي
فيما عزت الحاله لدى فتيات اخرى الى
التاثر النفسي او الخوف الجماعي اي القلق
عند رؤيه جميع زميلاتهن تظهر عليهن
الاعراض فيعانين من نفس الاعراض دون سبب
بحسب ما نقلته ايضا ايران انترناشونال
وزعم هنا مسؤول بوزاره الصحه ان اقل من
10% من حالات التسمم كانت اعراضا حقيقيه
اما معظمها فيتعلق بالتوتر وهنا طبعا
مشاهدينا مئات الايرانيين وبمقدمتهم
اولياء الطالبات الذين يشاهدون سقوط
بناتهم الواحده
تلو الاخرى منذ ثلاثه شهور كثفوا
احتجاجاتهم في الشارع حيث شهد الطهران
وشيراز والاهواز في وعده ايضا مدن في
كردستان ايران تجمعات احتجاجيه رغم
الاجواء الامنيه المشدده من قبل النظام
فيما قوات الامن هاجمت المحتاجين على
تسميم الطالبات في مدينه مشهد شمال شرق
ايران واستخدم طبعا الغاز المسير للدموع
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا عبر سكايب من اوسلو
عمار تساء عضو منظمه حقوق الانسان
الاحوزيه استاذ عمار يعني
نسعى النظام لاغلاق مدارس وجامعات للنساء
الذين
اعتبرنا العصب الاساسي للتظاهرات بالاشهر
الماضيه هو غير مخفي على احد ولكن التخبط
في الروايات الرسميه اليوم ومحاوله يعني
رمي الاتهامات جذافا الى اي مدى تظهر ضعف
النظام امام اراده النساء هناك
تحيه لك وللمشاهدين الكرام ما يظهره
النظام او ما قيل اليوم من قبل النظام
الايراني هو يظهر عدم جديه النظام
الايراني في متابعه هذه القضيه التي هي
امتدت لمده اكثر من ثلاثه شهور فمن غير
المعقول ان يكون النظام الذي يلاحق
يلاحق المعارضين في خارج حدود ويقتالهم
ويستطيع ان
يلقي القبض على على من يتجرا ويحرق صوره
او شيء خلال 24 ساعه يكون عاجز عن معرفه
مسبب او المسببين او الجهه المسببه لهذه
الحالات من التسمم بحسب الخبراء ان
الغازات التي يتم تسريبها ويتم انتشارها
ويتم الهجوم بها على المدارس هي مركبه ولا
يمكن للاشخاص العاديين ان يقومون بانتاج
مثل هذه الغازات وتحتاج الى ادوات ومختبر
وغيره فكيف على اجهزه النظام تعجز اجهزه
النظام الايراني عن ملاحقت هؤلاء ولكن
اعتقد انه من جهه تظهر عجز النظام وايضا
استخدام وسيله خبيثه لمنع الفتاه ولمنع
النساء من مواصله المسيره الثوره التي
بداناها قبل اربعه شهور وايضا بث حاله من
الرعب والهلع ووضع الشعوب الايرانيه امام
امام مفترق طرق احدهم الفوضى او او
المضيء قدما في هذه المظاهرات لاسقاط
النظام استاذ اعتقد يعني ايضا اليوم
النظام يواجه مشاكل في الداخل وفي الخارج
وطبعا ماذوم على المستوى السياسي والشعبي
وبالتالي هناك ناحيه اخرى من هذه الازمه
وهو موضوع يعني اشغال الراي العام بقضيه
اخرى
لكي يعني
يعميهم عن باقي القضايا المطروحه الاساسيه
اليوم في الداخل والخارج الى اي مدى يمكن
ان يساهم هذا الملف باشغال الراي العام
على على اي مدى واي فتره
بطبيعه الحال الراي العام الايراني الشعوب
الايرانيه هي قالتها وقالتها بالحرف
الواحد انها لا تريد هذا النظام وتريد
نظام ديمقراطي نظام عصري نظام لا يحمل
ايدولوجيه بافكار سوداء بافكار ظلاميه
وتريد نظام حديث وخاصه جيل الشباب
والمراهقين قالوا ذلك بوضوح واعتقد ان
النظام الايراني هو فقد البوصله تماما
وفقد صوابه في بدا يسمم ويقوم بهجمات
كيماويه على ابنائه وعلى الجيل الذي هو من
المفروض يكون جيل المستقبل واعتقد ان ان
هذا التخبط هو سوف يؤدي بهذا النظام الى
التهلكه وان النظام لا يدري ماذا يفعل لا
يدري لا يدري ماذا يقوم به وهذا بالعكس
لانه الشعوب الايرانيه هي لا تريد هذا
النظام وهذا مثل هذه الخطوات اعتقد تزيد
من سخط وتزيد من غضب الشارع الايراني على
النظام وسوف اعتقد ان هناك فئات اكثر حتى
الفئات التي كانت في المنطقه الرماديه او
المواليه للنظام سوف تنقلب على النظام
بسبب هذه الاعمال الاجراميه خصوصا اننا
نتحدث عن اباده يعني شعبيه اليوم ليس فقط
محاوله اسكات شكرا لك استاذ عمار تسائي
عضو منظمه حقوق الانسان الاحوازيه على هذه
المداخله
كشف مراسل العربيه عن ان هناك عقوبات
اوروبيه ضد مسؤولين في سجن قرجاك الايراني
على خلفيه العنف ضد المعتقلات وقال
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان المعتقلات والناشطات
منهن حاملات في سجن قرجا يعيشن بظروف
قاسيه في ظل ظروف التعذيب والاغتصاب
والعنف الجنسي كما اضاف الاتحاد الاوروبي
ان معتقلات هذا السجن يعانين من اقتضاض
الزنزانات والنقص العلاج وان السلطات
السجن الايرانيه تستخدم الاغتصاب كوسيله
لانتزاع الاعتراف من السجينات
[موسيقى]
الى ملف اخر حيث افاد مراسل العربيه
باقتحام قوات اسرائيليه خاصه مخيم جنين في
الضفه الغربيه فيما دوت صفارات الانذار في
المخيم بعد ما حاصرت القوات الاسرائيليه
منزلا وانزلعت اشتباكات عنيفه على اثرها
هذا واعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل سته
فلسطينيين في المخيم بينهم منفذ عمليات
حواء
شباب هيا هياها هيا اياد ثلاث شباب الناس
هياها هياها يا شباب
هيو شباب
كما افاد مشاهدينا مراسل العربيه باسقاط
طائره مسيره للقوات الاسرائيليه في مخيم
جنين
[تصفيق]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من جنين خالد القاسم
مراسل العربيه خالد يعني كيف هو الوضع
الامني هناك بعد انسحاب القوات
الاسرائيليه وهل يمكن القول بانه هدا يعني
بشكل تام وايضا يعني كما نشاهد هناك دمار
خلفك بالصوره اذا امكن ان تحدثنا عن ما
حصل خلال هذا النهار
نعم ليال نحن نتواجد في المنزل الذي
حاصرته القوات الاسرائيليه عند الثانيه
ظهرا بعد دخول قوات خاصه الى المنطقه
تابعتها قوات كبيره من الجيش الاسرائيلي
بمرافقه الطيران الذي حلق فوق المدينه
ومخيمها دخلت القوات الخاصه والجيش
الاسرائيلي حصلت هذا المنزل وامطرته بحسب
شهود العيان بسته عشر صاروخا بحسب خبرتهم
يقولون بانها صواريخ
انيرجا تهدمت كل جدران المنزل
وسقط في هذا المنزل اربعه من الفلسطينيين
وخارجه
اثنان اخران لتكون الحصيله ارتقاء سته
فلسطينيين وعصابه 17 اخرين اصابه اثنين
منهم حرجه الجيش الاسرائيلي والقوات
الاسرائيليه تقول بانها استهدفت في هذه
العمليه
الخليه التي تقف وراء عمليه اطلاق النار
في حواره الاسبوع الماضي والتي ادت الى
مقتل مستوطنين اثنين بحسب شهود العيان
ليال فانما جرى اليوم هنا في مخيم الجنين
هو الاعنف منذ العام 2000 منذ اجتياح مخيم
جنين في الانتفاضه الثانيه كم الرصاص
المتواجد
المنثور على الارض وكم الدمار الذي لحق
بهذا المنزل يدلل على حجم العمليه
العسكريه الذي التي شهدها مخيم جنين هذا
اليوم
شكرا لك خالد القاسم مراسل عربيه على هذه
الصوره والرساله من شنين
[موسيقى]
في تركيا حسمت صحف محليه الانتخابات في
البلاد قبل ان تبدا طبعا والفائز بحسب هذه
الصحف هو اردوغان اما السبب الاول في فوزه
هو منافسه كمال كرشدار اوغلو فبمجرد ان
اعلنت الطاوله السداسيه للمعارضه التركيه
ترشيح زعيم حزب الشعب الجمهوري مرشحا
للانتخابات الرئاسيه اعلن الصحيفه حريه
بان الرئيس التركي اردوغان هو المستفيد
الاكبر من هذا الترشيح
ويعتبر بان اوغلو هو المنافس الوحيد اليوم
للرئيس واوضحت الصحيفه ان كيلجار اوغلو
انتصر باتفاق احزاب المعارضه على اختياره
لتمثيلهم لكن المنتصر الاكبر هو اردوغان
الذي طالما اراد منافسه اوغلو اكثر من اي
شخص اخر ولكن لماذا يعني هذا الاصرار على
منافسته وليس شخص اخر الجواب بحسب الصحافه
المواليه فهو ان المعارضه برئاسه كمال
كلتشتار اوغلو لا تستطيع مجاراه حزب
العداله والتنميه لانهم لا يملكون انجازات
حقيقيه تؤهلهم للفوز في الانتخابات
المقبله كما انها اي المعارضه وعلى راسها
حزب الشعب الجمهوري هي من رفضت مقترح
اردوغان قبل سنوات حول البناء وخطط
اردوغان حول البناء الحضري الذي كان وفقا
لاعتقاد اردوغان سيخفف من اضرار الزلزال
المدمر الاخير في تركيا
فما
الاحزاب المعارضه وزعمها زعيم حزب الشعب
الجمهوري السيد كمال كليتجار اوغلو يقومون
بتحريض الشعب للوقوف ضدنا ووضعوا عراقيل
امام عجله النمو والتحول المدني في الماضي
والان يكررون نفس توجهاتهم
[موسيقى]
مع مرور شهر على زلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا قالت رئيسه برنامج الامم المتحده
الانمائي في تركيا ان الاضرار الناجمه عن
الزلزال المدمر في تركيا ستتجاوز المئه
مليار دولار
هذا التقييم لا يزال قيد المراجعه ومن
المفترض ان يتم الانتهاء منه في الوقت
المناسب لعقد مؤتمر المانحين في الاتحاد
الاوروبي في بروكسيل المقرر عقده في
السادس عشر من مارس لكن من الواضح ان
الاضرار الماديه وحدها ستقدر قيمتها باكثر
من 100 مليار دولار
[موسيقى]
قالت ونقلت رويترز عن وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان قوله ان
التقارير التي تتحدث عن وجود تباعد في
العلاقات مع الامارات مبالغ فيها كما قال
الامير فيصل بن فرحان ان وزير الطاقه يرى
ان السوق لا تحتاج لتغيير الانتاج هذا
العام واكد التزام السعوديه باستقرار سوق
النفط
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قيد
[تصفيق]
في فرنسا تجدد الاحتجاجات الرافضه لرفع سن
التقاعد وصدامات بين المتظاهرين والشرطه
[موسيقى]
نستكمل التاسع مشاهدينا من افغانستان حيث
اعلن الاتحاد الاوروبي انه فرض عقوبات على
وزير التعليم العالي ووزير الامر بالمعروف
والنهي عن المنكر في حكومه طالبان وذلك
لكونهما يقفان وراء قرارات منع النساء من
التعليم العالي والممارسات التي تفصل بين
الجنسين في الاماكن العامه
[موسيقى]
والى فرنسا حيث تشهد خروج مئات الالاف
احتجاجا على مشروع قانون اصلاح نظام
التقاعد وتحولت جزء من تلك التظاهرات الى
اشتباكات مع الشرطه الفرنسيه هذا ويعد هذا
التحرك امتدادا للتحركات سابقه اخرى حدثت
خلال الشهرين الماضيين الحراك ياتي تحت
شعار اغلاق فرنسا حيث سيشمل قطاعات
استراتيجيه معينه فضلا عن انه
سيمهد الطريق امام بدايه اضراب مفتوح يمتد
لعده ايام
[موسيقى]
لمزيد من التفاصيل ينضم الينا من باريس
بادي الدهوك مراسل العربيه فادي يعني في
التحرك او الجوله السادسه من هذه
الاحتجاجات كيف كانت الصوره اليوم وما هي
خارطه الاحتجاجات اللاحقه
اهلا ليال الاحتجاجات اليوم كانت عارمه
جدا وكانت اختبار لمدى جهوزيه النقابات
والمعترضين على قانون التقاعد بانهم سوف
يستمرون بتحركاتهم اليوم يمكن القول ان
هذه التحركات نجحت والزخم مستمر هناك
ارقام تصدر للتو الان عن اعداد المشاركين
الكونفدراليه العامه للعمل تقول ان هناك
ثلاثه ملايين ونصف المليون شخص تظاهره
اليوم في عموم انحاء البلاد لكن ارقام
الشرطه مختلفه وتقول ان هناك مليون و280
الف متظاهر نزلوا الى الشوارع ايضا
الكونفدراليه العامه للعمل قالت ان 700
الف 700 الف شخص فقط في العاصمه باريس
تظاهروا اليوم طبعا والتظاهرات عمت معظم
المدن الفرنسيه كان هناك قرابه 260 نقطه
تظاهر في مختلف انحاء البلاد هذه
التظاهرات كما ذكرتي ترافقت ايضا مع اضراب
حتى الان الاضراب اليوم نجح هناك عدد كبير
من القطاعات التي شاركت في هذا الاضراب
وهو مبدئيا سيستمر اعلن ان يوم غد سيكون
اضراب وحركه النقل سوف تكون مضطربه بشكل
كبير كما كانت هي اليوم وايضا بعد غد فيما
يخص قطاع الطاقه كان هناك انقطاع في
التيار الكهربائي في احدى المناطق او في
احدى البلدات في منطقه في شمال فرنسا قطعت
قطعت التيار الكهربائي عن نحو 2000 من
سكان هذه المنطقه نتيجه اضراب العمال في
تلك المناطق ايضا هناك عدد كبير من
المضربين كان في من شركه الكهرباء الوطنيه
كان هناك نصف الموظفين اضربوا اليوم
47.9% من الموظفين اضربوا عن العمل اليوم
وهذا اخر من انتاج الكهرباء في عدد كبير
من المحطات ايضا هناك اضراب العمال في
مصافي النفط وهذا الامر يثير قلقا في
فرنسا من ان تعيش البلاد ازمه وقود جديده
على غرار ما حصل في الاشهر الماضيه
فادي يعني كان هناك اخبار عن اجتماع سيعقد
من قبل النقابات الليله لتحديد خريطه
التظاهرات للايام والاسابيع المقبله هل
عقد هذا الاجتماع هل من خارطه معلنه
التظاهرات انتهت قبل قليل الاجتماع لم يتم
حتى الان او ربما يكون في هذه اللحظات هو
يجري لكن لم يعلن بعد عن شيء هناك ايضا
كان اجتماع او هناك جلسه استماع ومسائله
للحكومه في البرلمان ايضا هناك جلسه لمجلس
الشيوخ
لمناقشه هذا القانون قبل ساعه تقريبا بدا
نقاش البند المتعلق بزياده سن التقاعد او
رفع سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما لم يصدر حتى
الان معلومات جديده لكن الاجتماع كما
ذكرتي سيحدد اجتماع النقابات سيحدد سير
التظاهرات للايام المقبله
والنقابات تعول على صبر الفرنسيين وعلى
استعدادهم للتضحيه قليلا من اجل كسب هذه
المعركه ضد الحكومه واجبارها على التراجع
عن هذا القانون شكرا لك فادي الدهوك مراسل
العربيه حدثتنا من باريس
[موسيقى]
تقرير ان اسرى لي بعنوان انذار احمر حذر
من حرب وشيكا بين الصين واستراليا وسيبدا
بمجرد ان تعلن بكين الهجوم على تايوان في
التفاصيل ذكرت صحيفه سيدني مورنينج محذره
الاستراليين من انهم يواجهون خطر الحرب مع
الصين في غضون ثلاث سنوات في حين ان
البلاد غير مستعده لاي صراع مع القوه
الاسيويه العظمى الصاعده التحذير جاء على
لسان لجنه من خبراء الامن القومي جمعتها
الصحيفه وتوصلت الى ان الحرب قد تاتي في
وقت مبكر من عام 2026 مع غزو الصين نقطه
اشتعال الصراع المحتدم في المحيط الهادئ
لانه استراليا ستجد نفسها في خضم الحرب
على اعتبار احتوائها قواعد امريكيه
وبالتالي واشنطن ستستخدم الاراضي
الاستراليه للدفاع عن تايوان هذا واطلق
الخبراء في تقريرهم التحذير الانذار
الاحمر الذي يعدوه بمثابه جرس انذار كبير
القوات المسلحه الاستراليه والامه ككل
محذرين من ان بلادهم غير مستعده
[موسيقى]
حرب التكنولوجيا بين الولايات المتحده
والصين متواصله واخر فصولها يتعلق بحذر او
على الاقل تقييد تطبيق تيك توك جهود
التصدي لتهديدات التكنولوجيا الاجنبيه
وتحديدا الصينيه يقودها هذه المره عدوان
بمجلس الشيوخ الامريكي حيث سيكشف
السيناتور الديمقراطيه
والجمهوري جون سيون عن مشروع القانون الذي
يحمل عنوان تقييد ظهور التهديدات الامنيه
التي تهدد التكنولوجيا المعلومات
والاتصالات التشريع وان تمريره سيتيح
لاداره بايدن سلطات جديده تمكنها من حظر
تطبيق الفيديو المملوك للصين وتطبيقات
اخرى قد تشكل مخاطر امنيه غير ان صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز استبعدت ان يكون حاضر
التطبيق هو الهدف بل ابقائه تحت اعين
الحكومه فتطبيق تيك توك الذي يستخدمه اكثر
من 100 مليون امريكي تعرض مشاهدينا
متزايده بسبب مخاوف من انتهاء مسار بيانات
المستخدم في ايدي الحكومه الصينيه البيت
الابيض هنا من جهته رفض الاعلان عن تاييده
او عدم تاييده لمشروع قانون مجلس الشيوخ
وفقه ما ذكرته ويذكر بان الصين منعت منذ
فتره طويله العديد من الخدمات الامريكيه
عبر الانترنت ابرزها نذكر جوجل متى
[موسيقى]
نبقى في الولايات المتحده ايضا وباخبار
السوشيال ميديا حيث اثار العطل الاخير في
تويتر غضب ايلون ماسك مالك المنصه الزرقاء
اذ تبين ان العطل الفني الذي تعرض له
العصفور الازرق كان من صنع مهندس واحد وفق
صحف امريكيه الشركه تمكنت من اصلاح الخلل
خلال ساعتين الا ان ذلك لم يخفف من غضب
مالكها الملياردير الامريكي ايلون ماسك
ماسكا كدا ان اجراء تغيير داخلي ادى لبعض
النتائج غير المقصوده في اشاره الى انهاء
الوصول المجاني لتويتر اي بي اي واجهه
برمجه التطبيقات وهي الاليه التي يتم
بواسطتها ربط مكونات البرامج ببعضها
باستخدام مجموعه من التعريفات
والبروتوكولات هذا وكان ماسك عين مهندسا
واحدا فقط في المشروع وهو الذي اقدم على
اجراء تغيير سيء ادى الى تعطل واجهات
برمجه التطبيقات وتوقف ادواتها عن العمل
[موسيقى]
في الباديه قام نشطاء بايون بغمر مبنى
وزاره النقل الالمانيه بالطلاء والماء وحث
المسؤولين على العوده الى تدابير حمايه
المناخ فلنتابع
[موسيقى]
في حادث الصدام طائرتين خفيفتين خلال
مناوره فقد طيران ايطاليان حياتهما وفق
سلاح الجو الايطالي فقالت وكاله الانباء
الايطاليه ان الطائرتين من طراز
يوثمانيه تحطمتها بالقرب من مطار عسكري
احدهما سقطت على حقل والاخرى على سياره
متوقفه دون تسجيل اصابات على الارض
ختام التاسعه مشاهدينا مع العناوين
[موسيقى]
من بغداد واشنطن تحذران ايران وميليشياتها
اياكم من تعريض العراق والمنطقه للخطر
في طريقها للسقوط بيدي القوات الروسيه
اوكرانيا تنفذ انسحابا غير معلن منها
تروي للعربيه قصه تطوعها في القتال على
الجبهات الاماميه ضد روسيا
وفي ملف تصميم الطالبات بايران اكثر من
5000 حاله والغاز السام يقتحم القطارات
ايضا
مشاهدينا الى هنا اتي الى ختام التاسعه
ولكن اخبار العربيه مستمره والان الى 360
وزميله ميسون ميسون مساء الخير وماذا لديك
مساء الخير طبعا موضوع اوكرانيا يتصدر
هناك تخوفات ايضا من ان المخازن الدول
التي تقدم هذه الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا تنفذ
فنريد ان نعرف اذا كانت هذه التخوفات لدى
اوكرانيا وايضا تصريحات الرئيسي لينسكي
بانه لن يتخلى عن بخموت مهما كانت ثمن
بالاضافه للعديد من الملفات متابعينا